well
this is your daddy's
brought back from the war
figures time to pass it on
it's the best present i ever got thank
you
[Music]
how and why people from two points on a
map without even a straight line between
them can be connected
is at the heart of our story and knock
them stiff
you ever think about how we ended up
orphans living in the same house
i know what my daddy did
some people would say it's just dumb
luck
you take pictures i do i see a smile
pretty enough to photograph that is
others would tell you it was god's plan
blessed are they who hunger and thirst
for righteousness that ain't no preacher
he's as bad as they got on a damn radio
when people look back on it they had no
other choice
there's a lot of no good sons and
[ __ ] out there
[Music]
excuse me preacher you got time for a
center
you know i studied something it's called
the delusion
a belief that is untrue
it is our delusion to lead us to sin
delusions
[Music]
some people were born just so they could
be buried
[Music]
what i'm about to do i do
because i have to
not because i want to
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the movie
that tom holland and robert pattinson
made as you saw there's a bunch of other
marvel actors in this so it's like the
craziest marvel dc crossover spider-man
fighting batman in the winter soldier
the movie was even produced by mysterio
himself jake gyllenhaal so it's like
this crazy crossover i'll explain what's
going on in this but if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos
the russo brothers have also been doing
this with a lot of their other
non-marvel movies recently too where
they grab
a bunch of marvel actors including tom
holland they just made another movie
with tom holland this releasing later
this year called cherry
so you wind up seeing a whole bunch of
marvel crossovers outside of the mcu
but the movie is all about tom holland's
character and a bunch of other people
that live in the small town that he's
from he plays the main protagonist he's
one of the few
good well-meaning characters in the
story most of the other people that you
see show up in this trailer are all
really depraved and really twisted
robert pattinson plays this really evil
sadistic preacher generally bad dude as
you see during the trailer footage
sebastian stan plays a corrupt local
sheriff who allows a bunch of killings
to go unpunished
bill skarsgard plays tom holland's
father in the movie i know anytime he
shows up in a movie you think about it
and pennywise he was also in a show
called castle rock which is based on the
stephen king mythology
so he plays so many twisted characters
that anytime you see him pop up in a new
project you just wonder what crazy
things he's going to be doing
and he does get really really crazy in
this movie
the movie's mostly about tom holland's
character and the lessons that his
father
bill skarsgard taught him and how he
applies that to his life in the
intersection of a bunch of these
different characters and how they're all
connected
but it's mostly following tom holland's
character the movie starts right after
world war
ii bill skarsgard comes back from war
after seeing all these horrors
he finds this woman falls in love with
her on his way back to small town ohio
where he's from
that woman winds up becoming tom
holland's mother and they live a
relatively normal life but over the
years he becomes obsessed with
prayer as you see him out in the woods
here with all these crosses i'll explain
this in a second too it gets really
twisted
he slowly goes crazier and crazier until
tom holland's mother
gets cancer and bill skarsgard goes into
complete overdrive performing ritual
human sacrifice thinking that it'll
convince god to save her
when she still dies he winds up killing
himself in grief
then tom holland moves in with his
grandmother who you see during the
trailer meets this girl who his
grandmother has also taken in to care
for her father is this roaming preacher
that's only around for a little bit of
the story but she grows up without any
parents so that's why the grandmother
takes this girl in
but her mother actually has history with
tom holland's father so they actually go
way back
they're about the same age so they go to
school together they grow up they grow
closer together and things are
relatively normal in small town ohio
here
until they run afoul of robert
pattinson's demonic preacher character
no spoilers for what happens but as you
can see from the trailer footage
things get super spicy and really
gruesome
eventually tom holland's character has a
big standoff with him as you also see
during the trailer so spider-man does
get to fight batman
later in the trailer where you see them
running through the woods here you
actually get to see him fight sebastian
stan's corrupt sheriff character gets
super crazy
so spider-man gets his rematch with the
winter soldier after captain america
civil war
[Music]
guys look i'd love to keep this up but
i've only got one job here today and i
got to impress mr stark so
i'm really sorry
then obviously there's a lot of other
crazy stuff going on in the trailer here
jason clark's character
and his wife are just two roaming serial
killers that photograph and kill their
victims i feel like that's kind of
implied by the trailer footage here
you take pictures yeah then we're also
probably gonna kill you the movie is
coming out in a couple weeks so you have
a chance to see it on netflix but like i
said
jake gyllenhaal mysterio produced this
they actually filmed the movie right
after tom holland and jake gyllenhaal
finished filming spider-man far from
home
so if you wonder why they were posting
all those funny videos on the spider-man
far from home press tour much
later in the year it was because they
also just finished filming this separate
netflix movie is this dude press to
operate
no don't touch it um the reason being is
because
we peter parker and may just have
spoilers sorry no
it sounded like in talking about robert
pattinson
batman of it all this was also right
before he started filming tennant with
christopher nolan
he told a funny story on the set of that
movie obviously we're all still waiting
to see tennant
but he said that while they were filming
that he actually got to audition
for the batman movie and he had to trick
christopher nolan or
tried to trick him he said that
christopher nolan knew exactly what was
going on because he's such a powerful
person inside warner brothers he makes
so much money for them he knows about
all the movies that they're making
pretty much at any given time so in
order to go
audition for batman he tried to lie and
say there was a family emergency so he
could sneak away and audition for the
batman movie christopher nolan's like
you're definitely auditioning for batman
right so he had to come clean
but he gave him his blessing he said you
know good luck have fun with this
but just to be clear christopher nolan
doesn't have anything to do with the new
version of batman the matt reeves batman
trilogy that they're making it's just
that he's so
connected inside warner brothers system
that he always knows what's going on
and every once in a while people will
call him for advice on movies but he's
not an actual producer on the new batman
movie or anything like that
and if you really like seeing these
marvel reunions outside of the mcu
movies the russo brothers after they
finished filming avengers end game went
on to do a bunch of indie smaller
projects and netflix movies through
their own production banner they just
did another movie with tom holland
called
cherry which is going to be released
later this year they also just did a
netflix movie with chris hemsworth
called extraction which you all probably
heard
they also got the cinematographer from
avengers end game to be the director of
that movie so that was another big
marvel reunion outside of the mcu
but what's going to be happening in the
next week getting back into the world of
comic book movies is that we have dc
fandom and a lot of batman stuff coming
up next weekend
they're going to be showing off a whole
bunch from robert pattinson and matt
reeves new batman movie there'll be a
special panel
of course i'll do a video for any kind
of footage that they drop or any big
announcements
right now tom holland is filming an
uncharted movie for sony that's right
nathan drake uncharted movie coming
sometime next year hopefully the virus
doesn't slow things down too much
but then right after that later this
year they're going to be filming
marvel's spider-man 3 so we'll get a
whole bunch more spider-man related
stuff happening later this year of
course i'll do videos for all that stuff
they'll also be a bunch of venom two
stuff carnage happening and the morbius
movie
so between all the different sony venom
and marvel mcu spider-man movies next
year
there's gonna be a ton of spider-man
stuff happening and if you're a big
chris hemsworth fan he's also getting
ready to film a hulk hogan
biopic there's been a bunch of fan art
and deep fake videos of him as hulk
hogan
it's uncanny it's crazy how much he
looks like him back in the day
if you have any big questions about any
of the big marvel or dc movies that are
coming up though just let me know in the
comments
everyone click here for that brand new
spider-man 3 tom holland clip of him
talking about the movie
and click here for my brand new batman
preview video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
you